[Music]
it's lovely to see you again river babes
as always I'm your host Leon Aguilera
and this is your Sweetwater secrets
preview show for episode 217 chapter 30
then noose tightens now as promised I
spent my weekend interviewing the Stars
of Riverdale so from here on out every
episode of Sweetwater secrets will be
packed with exclusive scoop that you
don't want to miss and today Madelaine
Pech will be dishing all about Cheryl's
latest conundrum I think I figured it
out
plus I've got three tricky clues for you
to decipher before you watch this week's
episode but first let's relive your
hisses and kisses and thoughts about
last week's episode chapter xxix primary
colors we're gonna put the coffee in the
pot we're gonna let it percolate kicking
things off pearl wrote hi Leanne a huge
fan Thank You pearl just to add to your
list of hisses hisses to Archie for
choosing Hiram over his dad I mean come
on dude this is way past getting your
girlfriend's dad to like you I could not
agree with you more pearl and jazzy Abby
commented a billion kisses to Mary
Andrews for whooping Archie's a SS bow
be damned if I'm gonna sit here and
listen to you disrespect him preach
meanwhile we had lots of back-and-forth
comments about last week's catfight
between Salonika and Josie now Adrianna
Hoffmann posted hisses to Veronica
because of how she quote campaigned I
mean seriously buying people by giving
kisses and cupcakes and trying to bribe
because she's daddy's little rich girl
okay girl and Riverdale fan 101 said
welcome back girl I was so happy to see
Essel if only shouldn't spend the whole
episode throwing perfectly good
milkshakes on non milkshake worthy
people at least it was only strawberry
no one likes strawberry on the flip side
miss Riverdale wrote kisses to Josie for
finally standing up against Veronica no
hate please but I think someone had to
put her in her place and Riverdale's
vixen wrote I understand the Ethel and
Josie are mad at the lodges for what
they've done to their families but it's
not a reason to make V pay for every
especially not bully her in front of
everyone else she also added the hashtag
Veronica Lodge deserves better and
unicorn for life said in all caps is she
just gonna ignore that
Archie just ruined his and jugheads
friendship
yes unicorn for life I am going to
ignore that because these two boys have
been ruining their friendship every
other week so I'm sure everything's
gonna be just fine
I'm fine and Simone added this show has
gone from teen drama to The Sopranos
reloaded I'm not giving up on fpd being
the father also the DNA test only
confirmed that Hal wasn't the father but
what about Alice as the mother smirky
face
and lastly void vampire wrote kisses to
chonies almost kiss I'm damn ready for
Tony to save Cheryl from that horrible
place and finally kiss her girl this is
obviously to Penelope and Claudius
blossom seriously what is going on with
this family is killing family members
like a family hobby and I 100% agree
with you team Josie sorry the but
Karma's a [ __ ]
so yes there was lots of back and forth
on the Ronnie verse Josie catfight but
there was one thing that all Riverdale
fans agreed on this week and that was
sending hisses - Penelope blossom for
locking cheryl away at the sisters of
quiet mercy for conversion therapy so
I'm gonna let you all in on a little
secret
now madellaine herself was not too
pleased to hear about Cheryl's trip to
quiet Mercy either now take a look at
what she had to tell me during our
interview together cheryl has now been
kidnapped and taken by the sisters of
quiet Mercy conversion ok conversion
therapy we found it that she was gonna
be going through this really dark
storyline what was your reaction you
know at first I take it very personally
as Cheryl and I was like kind of
miserable and then I was like you know
what this is something that
unfortunately is still happening which I
didn't even know and to be able to bring
these things to light again which I feel
like my character does a lot of is
important and I like that I get to do
that and I really take it so seriously
and I really want to make sure I'm doing
a justice deep brush and you're going to
need to take plenty of deep breaths
while you watch this week's episode
which leads us to my three clues about
episode 217 here we go
now number one an off-screen phone call
will create chaos for one of Riverdale's
most respected families number 2 a
forgotten storyline from episode 203
chapter 16 the watcher in the woods is
brought back into the ring and number 3
as one character embraces their past
another person's future is uncertain and
there you have it now guys come back to
Sweetwater secrets after you watch
chapter 30 the news Titans for even more
exclusive answers from Madeline patch
about this week's biggest moment and yes
it has something to do as Shoni plus I
have a phallus update from matron amick
and Skeet Ulrich and I've got a warning
you guys now you will swoon but for now
please give this video a like and hit
the comments to see if you can solve my
three clues now I'll see you after the
episode for even more Sweetwater secrets
so Tata for now River babe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]